vamos otra vez con este ejemplo que vi
en el vídeo pasado en donde estoy en una
aldea y empecé un banco para poder
emparejar a los ahorradores con
oportunidades de inversión quiero hacer
esto por dos razones número uno para
explicar bien bien cómo gana dinero un
banco y también creo que este ejemplo
ayuda muy bien para enseñarte acerca de
un nuevo estado financiero del cual no
hemos hablado mucho el estado de
resultados con un poquito de suerte ya
entiendes lo de la hoja de balance
ahorita pasamos al estado de resultados
supongamos que esto de aquí es la hoja
balance al principio del primer año de
operación al mero inicio del año 1
déjame acordarme que dije según recuerdo
había dicho que había empezado con un
millón de pesos que no se me prestaron
mis amigos o que me gané en la lotería
no sé no me importa como tuve el capital
el chiste es que invertir un millón de
pesos
con este dinero compre un edificio o lo
construí bueno la idea es que ahí
podamos poner el dinero y que se vea
súper súper seguro el chiste es que la
gente diga me late dejar mi dinero ahí
entonces ahora tenemos un millón de
pesos
en bienes raíces y luego el resto de la
aldea vio este bonito edificio que
construir y pues pues me dio parte de
sus ahorros dijo uff eso de allá es un
lugar que se ve súper seguro para
guardar mi dinero más que mi colchón o
acabarlo en mi patio y pues además sal
me dice que me va a dar interés por mi
dinero entonces pues como sal es muy
confiable es muy tiene una muy buena
reputación
entonces le voy a depositar mis ahorros
entonces obtuve 10 millones de pesos en
depósitos
y por supuesto les dije sabes qué bueno
estás aquí no es un préstamo no es como
que yo lo esté tomando prestado ustedes
pueden usar el dinero cuando quieran y
justo por eso pues o sea como lo tengo
que regresar tengo que apartar un
poquito por si alguien llega y dice
sabes que te di 100 pesos pero ahora los
necesito de vuelta para pagar la clase
de ballet de mi hija o lo que sea
entonces necesito apartar un poquito y
dije bueno sabes que es voy a apartar
10% yo espero que nadie pida más que eso
entonces pues por esto voy a apartar 10%
del dinero como una reserva de eso es
una reserva en efectivo el 10% es un
millón de pesos un millón de pesos en
efectivo
en efectivo si por alguna razón yo creo
que hay una mayor probabilidad de que
venga mucha gente para pedir su dinero
por alguna razón pues voy a hacer una
reserva un poco más grande después resto
quedé con 9 millones de pesos y esos 9
millones de pesos pues lo que voy a
hacer es prestar los de modo que se
vuelvan capital productivo es decir que
sea recuerda que la capital es el
derecho que tiene alguien para reclamar
bienes y servicios para construir o
hacer algo que cree más valor que con el
que se empezó va entonces esto de aquí
es 9 millones en préstamos a lo mejor te
has dado cuenta que siempre hablo en
estos términos como de adquisición hago
esto por una razón porque creo que la
sociedad de ahora estamos tan clavados
con los puntos de dinero o vaya con los
billetes de pesos que casi siempre nos
olvidamos que representan estos puntos
los puntos representan derecho a pedir
bienes y servicios y me ha pasado que
hay personas obsesionadas con bueno un
ejemplo es que recibo así un montón de
correos de personas que quieren muchos
puntos más en sus cuentas pero pues
simplemente es un número
importante es realmente que representan
estos puntos y que representan los
puntos en dinero pues en dinero esto
quiere decir que tienes derecho a
adquirir bienes y servicios pero bueno
regresemos a la hoja de balances al
inicio del año 1 ya con los préstamos
dije que iba a pedir un 10% de interés
en estos préstamos y soy bien optimista
supongo que todos van a pagar o sea que
ninguno va a caer en incumplimiento de
deuda
entonces entonces qué sucede en el
transcurso de este año cuánto interés
cuántos ingresos en intereses voy a
obtener ingreso en intereses ingreso en
intereses vamos a ponerle link int
ingreso en intereses es 9 millones por
10 por ciento es 900 mil pesos a 900 mil
pesos y cuánto es mi casto en intereses
a lo mejor debía haber hecho esto en
verde bueno gasto en intereses gasto en
intereses bueno pues a ver tuve que
pagar un 5 por ciento de los 10 millones
eso de ahí es 500 mil lo voy a poner
como un número negativo porque es un
gasto bueno como ya hice gasto debería
de ser positivo ahorita no importa mucho
son convenciones contables entonces le
pongo menos 500 mil pesos
luego para operar este banco necesito
más dinero hay que limpiar el edificio
tenemos que tener cajeros hay que
pagarle a los guardias de seguridad ya
los guardias hay que pagarles pues
macanas y uniforme en fin tengo varios
gastos más que van más allá de las
transacciones de intereses entonces
pongamos en nuestros estados salarios
estos son más gastos
salarios supongamos que tenemos que
pagar pues no sé menos 50 mil al año en
salarios que tengo que pagar y además
necesito hacer mantenimiento tengo que
pintar tengo que arreglar desperfectos y
ya sabes también tengo que comprar
bloques de mármol para dar esta
superioridad eh impenetrabilidad y de
seguridad en fin tengo que super cuidar
mi fortaleza y por lo tanto gasto mucho
mucho en mantenimiento digamos que son
cincuenta mil
entonces cuánto me queda hasta ahorita
pues es 900.000 menos 500 mil es 400.000
menos otros 100 mil 300 mil ahora aunque
esta aldea es muy primitiva no es tan
primitiva como para no tener impuestos
entonces esto de aquí es mi ingreso
antes de impuestos
creo que está sonando algo a lo lejos
bueno lo voy a ignorar es un poco
difícil pero bueno estoy aquí es mi
ingreso antes de impuestos y aquí el
gobierno de la aldea dice sabes que pues
hay servicios que yo pongo como las
carreteras el ejército la salud social
así que me vas a tener que dar una parte
entonces le pongo por aquí que pagó el
impuesto sobre la renta supongamos que
es de un tercio es decir pago 100 mil
pesos vale ya cumplí mis obligaciones
fiscales cuánto me va a quedar cuánto
sería mi ingreso neto ingreso neto
300.000 menos 100 mil que son 200 mil
magnífico ahora nada más para que lo
sepas esto de aquí es el estado de
resultados ahorita voy a hablar de cómo
se relaciona con las hojas de balance
pero antes de esto déjame encerrarlo en
un cuadrado para que parezca una hoja y
si se vea como un estado financiero
listo y cómo se va a ver mi hoja de
balance al final del año pues este
estado justo nos da los cambios en el
año bueno empecemos estos préstamos
todavía números han pagado simplemente
me pagaron
por ciento de interés entonces todavía
tengo estos préstamos en la hoja de
balance tenemos nueve millones en
activos que son esos préstamos que no me
han pagado vamos a los bienes raíces
ahorita pues todavía tengo el edificio y
como además gaste cincuenta mil pesos de
mantenimiento se compensa con el
desgaste y mi edificio sigue valiendo un
millón de pesos 1 millón 9 millones de
deudas ahora antes tenía un millón de
pesos en efectivo y estoy suponiendo que
realmente no cambio que nadie depósito
más dinero va muy bien entonces empecé a
teniendo un millón de pesos en efectivo
nadie depositó sin embargo en el
transcurso del año obtuve 200 mil y
claro los voy a tener en efectivo muy
bien entonces ahora tenemos 1.2 millones
1.2 millones de pesos en efectivo los
depósitos los depósitos tampoco
cambiaron entonces sigo teniendo 10
millones en depósitos 10 millones en
depósitos que siguen siendo pasivos en
realidad
la gente puede venir cuando quiera por
su dinero baja que es lo único que falta
cuánto es mi capital mi capital al
inicio era un millón cuál es mi capital
actual bueno pues el capital es activos
totales menos pasivos totales a ver es
nueve más uno es diez más 1.2 es 11.2
millones en activos totales menos los
pasivos menos 10 es 1.2 millones de
capital 1.2 millones de capital ahora
ahí te va una pregunta interesante cuál
fue mi cambio en el capital al principio
tenía un millón en capital ahora tengo
1.2 millones en capital entonces mi
cambio de capital que va de un millón a
1.2 millones vamos a escribirlo como lo
escribimos
no sé si quieres utilizar la anotación
matemática
podemos utilizar la anotación de delta
este triangulito es delta entonces el
cambio en capital fue igual a 200 mil
pesos
y algo curioso eso es lo mismo que el
ingreso neto entonces qué es un estado
de resultados bueno aquí ya puse un
estado de resultados pero como se
conecta con las hojas de balance o con
los estados de flujo de efectivo que
vamos a ver después bueno pues una hoja
de balance es simplemente una fotografía
de lo que tienes en determinado momento
del año esta es la hoja de balance al
inicio esta es la hoja de balance al
final esta es la foto de lo que teníamos
y debíamos al inicio y esta es la foto
de lo que tenemos y debemos al final del
año el estado de resultados lo que te
dice es que pasó en el transcurso del
año
entonces esencialmente dice como pasamos
de la primera hoja de balance a la
última otra forma de pensarlo es que la
hoja de resultados nos dice los gastos
que hubo de los salarios del
mantenimiento los pagos de impuestos
etcétera y luego al final de la hoja
viene un ingreso neto y ese ingreso neto
es justo el cambio en el capital de este
modo si tienes un ingreso neto positivo
entonces en la hoja de balance se va a
reflejar en un cambio en esa cantidad en
el capital del mismo modo si el ingreso
neto es negativo
entonces en la hoja de balance el
capital va a disminuir en la cantidad
del ingreso neto entonces justo el
ingreso neto es el cambio en el capital
otra cosa de la que queremos hablar es
del retorno sobre el capital puede saber
empezamos con un millón de pesos en qué
porcentaje aumentamos ese capital pues a
ver llegamos a 1.2 millones entonces
tenemos que hacer 200 mil dividido entre
entre un millón una vez lo voy a poner
así como mil miles y eso es igual a 20
por ciento es decir eso ahí es el
retorno en el capital pusimos un millón
y nos dio 20 por ciento de la cantidad
va esto es igual a hereu que es el
retorno de capital por sus siglas en
inglés recuerda el retorno sobre el
capital es exactamente lo mismo que el
cambio de capital dividido entre capital
inicial es igual al ingreso neto el
ingreso neto dividido entre el capital
inicial bueno le estoy diciendo capital
inicial pero otras personas lo conocen
como capital promedio otras cosas pero
bueno espero que esto haya sido una
buena herramienta para explicar un
poquito esto
estado de resultados y lo importante fue
ver cómo se conectan
de hecho en contabilidad eso es lo padre
que diferentes tipos de estados
financieros están entrelazados aquí con
dos hojas de balance se puede construir
un estado de resultados para ver qué
pasó en el transcurso nos vemos